[Music]
we are a circus of big family tradition
and with the way we present our show is
the same way that my family presented
the show over 175 years ago there's
nothing fancy about what we do here it's
magic real magic we grew up in a circus
as a child you just stepped into being a
clown we're a classic family circus
which means our family's here working
together performing together first of
all does my mother the matriarch of our
family then I have my sister Carla who
with her husband Rudy they perform with
her dog act and then way my sister Tosca
she has her horses on the show but she
also directs the show her husband J is
an amazing white clown the white clown
is the stray clock he's the best white
palm that I've ever seen
knack that my son and I do right now in
a show is actually a balloon routine
it's nothing new I mean it's thousands
of years old cause haven't done it
forever
it happens to be really cute when he
does it because he's adorable
it's an it's a unexplainable thing to
see my child do what he loves to do I
mean this egg it's a seven-year-old
beautiful little boy and his heart opens
up and he gives it to everybody it's
different here I think for the most
person when we come into this ring we
become family
I believe circus and family are
basically the same word
[Music]
the first ride is the straight wall ride
the second act is our go-kart so it's
four wheels this time
bird fits right in one of these lovely
ladies and when you do hands off
stand it up hands off sitting on the
sides standing on the side as a whole
array of acts it's an experience you
can't prepare anything in the world too
I'm Kerry Cameron and I'm wall of death
Rider and I ride for Luke Fox's original
wall of death I started writing the wall
of death by pure accident I used to work
with horses
and unfortunately where I was working in
the place shut down
so naturally we went to the Jobcentre
and I just typed in horse rider into the
search engine and we'll add if rider
came up and I went down to the art and
they had the wall built up I knew there
and then that was it
you do you're very dizzy in your first
man's ride because you've got buildings
down there up to the dizziness it has to
go at least 30 mile an hour to stay on
with otherwise gravity will just whip
you straight off it's a mixture free
thing so balance speed and I'll see a
bit of stamina just lifting your arm up
it's a way of good bias the audience is
quite a feat it's a good feeling being a
female rider in this masculine vironment
it gives me a great buzz because a lot
of people when they see you walk into
the wall they just think they're a bit
of flash you know but as soon as they
see you get on the bike you can hear
like murmurs saying oh there's a girl on
a motorbike see all their faces light up
and then after the show all the girls
they're like wow you've got bigger balls
and roses and then but but it's great to
know that they look at you thinking
wooly if you could do it then
[Music]
[Music]
oh boy
[Music]
there's a certain feeling of adrenaline
once you get up there in the air it's a
feeling unlike any other you feel power
you feel like you're in control you feel
special
that's what makes trapeze beautiful
that's what makes the circus beautiful
[Music]
my name is Kristen Finlay and I'm a
trapeze artist 15 years ago I was
working for a brewery in Los Angeles I
had a great life making great money I
had you know my Lexus and I had a house
I was only you know twenty four years
old
a friend of mine told me that she was
flying trapeze and I said what are you
doing I want to come watch I ended up
taking a class and I was hooked it was
addictive ride away
and I quit my life in LA and I joined
the circus
I went from good paid to zero pay just
had to give everything up pretty much
overnight and here we are 15 years later
I never looked back and I've been on the
road ever since to run away and join the
circus it takes commitment you have to
be ready for anything you have to kind
of live on your toes because you never
know what's gonna happen your own
personal space your RV or whatever
that's your home and that's what has to
be stable inside whenever you're flying
trapeze you have to focus on what you're
doing and the moment you doubt yourself
in the middle of a trick most likely
you're going to mess up you're not going
to make it the fact that I was able to
do it made it more appealing to me and
I'm doing these tricks and they're
harder and they're harder and this is
awesome
whatever you want to do in your wildest
dreams do it
anything's possible there's not too many
african-american female circus
performers but I was still able to do it
your life is what you make of it and I
wouldn't change my life for the world
I really wouldn't you get skinny and
then you want to cover it up I just wore
clothing baggy clothes things that hid
my body I would have little games in my
head that I would play like let's see
how long I can go without eating I would
definitely still be starving myself if I
had not gone circus arts
[Music]
I'm Kayla dykes and I'm a professional
aerialist and a survivor of anorexia I
did gymnastics and developed anorexia
and my pains into my 20s at my lowest
point I was 90 pounds and that's when I
discovered circus arts it changed my
life because I knew that if I wanted to
do it I needed to grow stronger and grow
from it it took me eight years to get
from there to here anorexia never really
goes away you just learn how to shut it
out
when I look in the mirror now I don't
see the muscle mass I feel small
almost immediately I'm thinking you know
that's not true you can climb 200 feet
straight up I had no idea from my first
day that this would end up being my
profession back then you know I would
cook a pot of noodles and I would have
to get my then-husband to strain the
noodles for me because I didn't have the
strength to lift the pot of water
noodles and pour it out and I remember
asking like what is wrong with me and
one of my trainers looked at me and she
said you need to eat I had fallen in
love with Arielle so much so that I was
willing to put food in my mouth and grow
some muscle so I can get up in the air
and keep up with all my classmates
[Music]
I could say anything to my anorexic self
it would be that you could be so much
nicer to your body at the time I thought
I was taking care of it I wasn't and I
didn't know any better
I'm capable of so much more
[Music]
when I'm juggling I feel like I have a
superpower to me it's just an amazing
feeling to keep lots of things in the
air and to keep these big patterns going
[Music]
Sam Malcolm is a combat juggler the
object of the sport it's to keep all
three pins in the air while preventing
your opponent from doing likewise like
bumping and um - um altercations are
permitted the last juggler standing wins
I got into combat juggling at about 3
a.m. at a juggling convention
playing around with some friends just
trying to see who could be the last one
standing
we've all been to circuses we've all
seen variety acts but this is something
that makes it more of a sport if you're
playing football you have to put in the
work to get good at football juggling is
no different you have to put in hours
and hours and hours of practice you're
not only accounting for the three
objects that you're juggling you have to
anticipate that there could be something
flying at your head from 50 feet in the
air because it's so held and crazy
there's so many other people playing I
warm up for combat juggling I jump rope
for about 10 minutes I work on balancing
things when my head and on my face
there's a lot of wild throws there's a
lot of wild saves there's a lot of
jumping around and falling and running
on the ground and I try to go through
all of those things to get ready
you see incredible plays by people like
Steph Curry or LeBron James I can look
at those people and tell you like they'd
be great jugglers because I have that
awareness suffers their body it's
something new and exciting and fresh
something fun it's something different
so I'm optimistic that it'll grow and
become something really great
[Music]